we're living in a time where the last  two and a half years uh if you want to  talk about divide and conquer you know  split the country you know magic crowd  hates the other side the other side  hates Mega crowd look at these  Republicans these Democrats provacs  anti-vaxx it's so much about you know I  was on a flight the other day guy  sitting next to me on the flight back  from DC the entire time he had his uh he  had his mask on in your mind you already  can say this person voted for you know  what kind of Channel he watches you can  probably list 20 things this guy does  and then you know it's unfortunate but  we kind of are doing that